in this san salvador prison a
humiliating spectacle forced on hundreds
of gang members who are now inmates
they're head shaven and forced to run
half naked before the cameras these men
are getting a taste of what their
president warns could be even worse
treatment
more than a thousand members of what are
arguably the world's deadliest rival
gangs were captured 24 hours after
president naib bukele ordered a state of
emergency
it followed a wave of gang murders that
left at least 60 people dead in a single
day on saturday
the measure suspends the right to
assembly privacy of communications the
need for an arrest warrant and the right
to legal counsel but that's not all
the president has sent the country's
seventy thousand gang members a tweet
stop the killings he says or the
prisoners will pay the price
human rights watch tells al jazeera
bouquet is in fact mimicking the conduct
of drug traffickers what he is
implementing in in el salvador
is typical um
tactics of uh of a mafia state where you
take revenge
um
against
uh other members of the
family
that is obviously it's not the way
in in a country where there is rule of
law
the former director of the
intra-american human rights commission
paolo abrao calls the president's
actions penal populism by countering
barbarism with barbarism
but phuket is unapologetic accusing the
international organizations that
sponsored a truce between el salvador's
warring gangs in 2012 for allowing them
to accumulate resources money and
weaponry
puquela says the gang members will get
limited food and have had their
mattresses confiscated and that they
will quote not see the light of day
they'll also be confined to themselves
indefinitely except of course for these
exhibitions designed to make it clear
that he means business
to see newman al jazeera